abrimos o morimos bajo este lema y
cacerola en mano el gremio de
restauración de ciudad de mexico
protesta en contra de las medidas que
les impiden abrir sus establecimientos
ante el aumento de hospitalizaciones en
la capital de méxico el gobierno local
decretó semáforo rojo el pasado 19 de
diciembre lo que implica el cierre total
de la restauración salvo servicios a
domicilio pero más de 500 restaurantes
desafiaron la medida y decidieron abrir
sus puertas alegando que se trata de una
medida desesperada lo que pasa que no no
pudimos lograr un acuerdo a pesar de que
les dijimos que vamos a ir no nos
creyeron que estábamos dispuestos a
abrir
estamos tan desesperados que estamos
abriendo porque si no la opción que nos
dieron es la muerte el pasado 7 de enero
más de 500 empresas emitieron un
comunicado solicitando diálogo a las
autoridades pero por el momento no han
recibido respuesta y alegan que acatarán
las medidas del gobierno siempre que se
les dé una solución para poder abrir
y cada día perdemos más puestos de
trabajo
no sé a dónde porque en frente tampoco
se nos van a ver porque también cerraron
y las autoridades nos están entendiendo
no nos están ayudando de verdad estamos
muriéndonos la solución para los
restaurantes podría llegar con el avance
de la vacunación masiva que este martes
pasar a una fase de expansión que
extenderá la vacunación para el personal
médico de los 32 estados del país el
gobierno anunció también que este martes
recibirá el primer cargamento masivo de
la vacuna pzifer y la posibilidad de
adquirir 24 millones de dosis de la
vacuna rusa